hello and welcome to video playing
surfer rosa and oh the london yeah this
line is actually quite interesting it's
difficult Queen B 2 is a draw for straw
but I don't want to force draw so I'm
taking in to try to play for win here I
will try to show you later why if this
is the first draw if I remember probably
not a 3 now is them normal move no he
does allow queen bee to this will be 2
95 96 probably still this kind of this
draw anyway okay i can i can develop for
a normal plane
okay I think this Bishop is does not
really feel like it's doing much so I'm
trying to take on f3 and play Knight to
c6 get some pressure against that you
for porn yo it's a good move
and if I was very annoying so okay let's
get out of that
yeah I wonder is this a this is an equal
position always white banner with his
Bishop with his bishops and my pieces
are not that bad playing some generally
useful museum without a completely clear
plan admittedly i'm not sure that i want
to commit with with something here
rather want to wait and see what he is
doing I came he will not play before
that's a very weird move but now I could
take a three have before his complete
nonsense yeah d 5 is an idea but he can
take it 95 and I'm losing a pawn so I
cannot play this 65 so he allows the
current rate okay I'm going for that and
now yeah I wonder I think d5 is probably
right trying to put the pawns here on
light squares for a very healthy
structure he wants to go 93 c 5 foot I
cannot do much about that
okay the night c5 okay but I have this
one night to see form okay so he's going
all the way back probably to see one I
Scott Bishop g5 as a threat cell I have
to leave the e-file yeah what about this
position as a somewhat better square i
think then g7 maybe you can continuously
attack my book now nope he wants to do a
little bit more in this pollution ok it
slightly annoying I cannot go i cannot
go bishop the eight because of Bishop
age 60 my should be should be more
focused here
i goes for each one mmm that looks a bit
uncomfortable push it back okay will not
change will probably move it back
yeah his thread was to check and play
Bishop age 60 I had to do something
about it I didn't want to play g5 why
does just more comfortable here yeah g5
if he goes g45 he's worsening his own
Bishop a little bit now he tries to
double up okay
g5 and this age 6 okay I don't know how
bad that is oh ok so I'm able to support
this he's got f4 but again i'm not sure
how bad this is can I do something
myself that's difficult I can get this
to c6 at least the time situation is
okay
check okay this is a piece trading one
Bishop check time warning DRA offered
all right when okay I'm I'm the position
is not great but he has no time can I do
anything very difficult for any way to
try to do something here I can try to to
enter with both rooks am generally he
can do the same and a chant that didn't
help check check yeah I know I just
blundered this bloody porn check check
check white person's yeah okay cannot to
take draws every time you head on the
clock when you goose yeah I don't know
it was tough I was probably worse
throughout
at the beginning of this it was probably
ok but then I drifted towards a bad
position now this is definitely okay for
black but I never really am I didn't
address the whole kingside play well I
just lost lots of time and this is um
yeah this is got really really
uncomfortable all this business here I
was surprised though that he didn't play
age six year this was kind of clear I
thought that he would play this shyness
and dis highlighting the weakness of the
pawn Jim didn't do that and now I felt I
should be okay again but probably I
didn't didn't play this route whooping
well Joe it seems he he had a bigger
opportunity taking here first and then
this he's a very strong move 4936 later
I was a very bad position check check I
know I can actually take a plane 95 and
then I'm okay again yeah it's clear with
this kind of time there will be will be
mistakes yeah I thought I might have
something against the pawn their on G
forward Chad of course that's not the
case right here start to be be okay and
better yeah it was a time scramble time
scramble kind of game and the opening
the thing is a black can take here but
this is a draw because why does have
nothing
better than 95 then 95 and now the best
thing that I can do is take the draw
with rook B 1 a 1 the perpetual him
other other tries are are not really
great yeah why does a pawn down
otherwise this is a good line for black
if you want to draw against somebody
where this is an okay result I mean it's
not the most exciting approach but yeah
it's a it's a line if you're okay with
the draw this is an all time high by the
way yeah 25 24 so two more two extra
points compared to 2m some games before
okay well thanks for watching